we have already introduced ourselves to
the idea of price discrimination in
other videos and in this video we're
going to try to classify the different
ways that a firm might engage in price
discrimination so first of all just as a
review of what it is this is when a firm
charges different prices to different
consumers in order to capture as much of
the consumer surplus as possible in
other videos we visualize that by
showing the consumer surplus and showing
how a firm might visually try to eat
into that consumer surplus but let's
talk about the different types so the
first type of price discrimination is
known as first degree
first
degree
price discrimination often known as
perfect price discrimination and this is
really the most theoretical of all of
the ones we're going to talk about
in first degree or perfect price
discrimination the firm is able to
essentially capture the entire consumer
surplus by charging each individual
exactly what they are willing to pay
now in order to pull this off you would
have to magically be able to know what
someone is willing to pay when they show
up you say oh i'm gonna charge you five
dollars because you can read their mind
that they're willing to pay exactly five
dollars and the next person to walk in
you say i'm gonna charge you four
dollars because you know they could that
that's exactly what they're willing to
pay now in the real world we can't get
to that level of precision but firms can
try to get there
now a general principle that's true that
needs to be true to do first degree
price discrimination or really any type
of price discrimination is the different
users shouldn't be able to know what the
other person is getting it for and they
shouldn't be able to trade between them
so there's one principle when we're
talking about price discrimination where
there is no arbitrage
arbitrage arbitrage is just a fancy word
for if i know something is i can buy it
for five dollars over here and if i can
sell it for seven dollars over here well
then it would be very natural for
someone to buy it for five and sell four
seven
and so if someone if there were a firm
that were out there doing first degree
price discrimination but if people knew
about it well then they could say hey
you over there you're willing to pay
five and that's what the firm is
charging you but i know a place because
the firm is willing to sell it to me for
three so i'll buy it for three and sell
it to you for five so in order for price
discrimination in general to happen
especially something like perfect or
first degree price discrimination you
need to have no arbitrage
now the next type of price
discrimination is known as and this is
no surprise second degree
second degree
price discrimination and this is a
situation where a firm is going to
charge different folks different prices
based on
quantity that they are going to buy and
you might have seen this where you might
have things like bulk discounts
bulk
discounts
and so it's a way of differentiating to
some degree it's unlikely that the firm
is able to capture the entire consumer
surplus but you could say hey you know
the big contractor that needs to buy a
lot of wood they might have a lower
willingness to pay so let's give them a
lower price based on volume while the
hobbyist who just needs to buy a little
bit of wood we can charge them a higher
price based on their lower volume so
here you're talking about price versus
quantity
and then you could go to and once again
no surprise third degree
price discrimination
and third degree price discrimination
this is when you are looking at a
characteristics of the consumer
so
consumer
or i should say maybe buyer
so this is based on buyer
characteristics
so the class example of third degree
price discrimination is when you go to a
museum there might be they might have a
different price for seniors or for young
children versus for adults and the
reason why they do that is they might
say hey seniors might have a lower
willingness to pay but we want them to
come anyway they might do it for other
reasons as well just for for good social
values whatever else but it could also
be it is by definition a form of price
discrimination you're giving a different
price to different people based on who
they are
now in the real world what firms try to
do is some combination of various types
of price discrimination and they could
also vary the actual products a little
bit so that they aren't perfectly
identical